[Music]
following asap rocky's arrest wednesday
morning in connection with a los angeles
shooting last year e.t is learning how
his girlfriend rihanna who is pregnant
with their first child is handling it
just hours later after returning from
their vacation in the singer's home
country of barbados the rapper was
arrested at los angeles international
airport for assault with a deadly weapon
and new details are emerging the lapd
says on november 6 2021 an argument
between two acquaintances occurred in
the hollywood area the authorities add
the argument escalated and resulted in
the suspect firing a handgun at the
victim the victim sustained a minor
injury from the incident and later
sought medical treatment following the
shooting the suspect and two additional
males fled the area on foot
but amid all this ree only has one thing
on her mind her pregnancy a source tells
e.t this drama is the last thing rihanna
needs right now she wants to be mellow
relaxed and focused 100 on the arrival
of her baby not stressing out rihanna
made a point to navigate the public side
of her pregnancy on her own terms and
now suddenly things seem out of her
control
but despite the news of asap's arrest
since announcing the news they were
expecting in january the two have been
over the moon about becoming parents
what are you looking forward to as you
move into a new chapter of your life i'm
just excited for what i don't know yet
you know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited and ree has been
slaying all the looks with her adorable
baby bump
but you were making it look so stylish
you're having fun with it well you have
to right see that i mean so it's a long
nine to ten months girl you know you you
have to enjoy it you are making it your
fashion show i'm trying to enjoy it as
much as i could and fashion is one of my
favorite things so you know redefining
what it means to even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend
and turns out the goldie wrapper has
been her rock throughout the pregnancy
back in february a source told e.t asap
has been tending to all of rihanna's
needs and they are really enjoying this
moment together as a couple rihanna and
asap have such a strong bond and they
can't wait to experience parenthood
together what are you enjoying about
this journey with three right now
everything about it i'm loving it taking
care of a girl absolutely as for what's
next for the couple when it comes to
their little one's arrival our source
says the fenty beauty founder is focused
on having the baby in barbados
[Music]
you